[Music]
hi river babes you're here and I'm happy
so let's get started
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
Riverdale episode 307 chapter 42 the man
in black
now today I'll be teasing you with my
three top secret clues about this
special three-part episode as well as
bringing you an exclusive interview with
Riverdale's most frustrating mama
Machin Amick talking about one of season
three's biggest mysteries but first I'm
diving into last week's comments section
and taking a look at your top kisses
kisses and theories from episode 306
chapter 41 Manhunter kicking things off
it's just Rose X commented kisses - how
you guys head 'it scenes from the
episode to make an iconic reaction oh
thank you so much you know my editor
Hank and I sit together and work a lot
of late nights to find fun ways to use
the Riverdale episode in our Sweetwater
after shows so I really appreciate that
you guys have been noticing and enjoying
our fun little cutaways I'm obsessed
with everything that just happened
moving on juju beans said my initial
thoughts when Veronica opened the
computer file was why did it have the
sacrifice symbol why I would hire him
name the file after G&G when he has
nothing to do with the game something
smells fishy
I agree juju beans something does smell
fishy
probably not hiring himself because I
would imagine he would smell
frustratingly wonderful yeah but I do
agree that it was very weird that he had
the G&G symbol on the file I will say
that I would be extremely annoyed if he
was the man in black because it just
seems too damn obvious
next up lovely and posted kisses to the
amazing screen parallels especially the
phallus hug but hisses to the suspicious
look between FP and Betty I know right
and a lot of you agreed with my theory
that something is not quite right with
FP Nebula ramen added now that you've
pointed out on FP I agree with you on
how suspicious he was in this episode I
have a feeling he was the one who
convinced Alice to put her in the
sisters of quiet mercy and Alice must be
hiding something too in fact all the
parents are starting to seem so shady
yes so damn Shady
can someone please turn on a Riverdale
night light because I need to know who
to trust I thought we could trust Alice
what but wick Turia crews luck I hope I
said that right point it out hisses to
the fact that the writers are making
Alice a cruel mother when she's
obviously not give us our Alice back you
know I think she belongs to the farm now
and speaking of the farm
Jules Brown offered a new theory and
said the man in black could be Edgar
ever never a leer of the colt cuff cuff
I mean the farm who that would be
interesting now let's dig deeper into
this Edgar ever never shall we now that
we know that Alice has officially
ditched her daughter so that she can
frolic off with him at the farm I think
it's time that we dive deeper into this
m.i.a character now here's what matron
Amick had to tell me about this
mysterious man that we've yet to meet
Edgar ever never very mysterious very
alluring you know I think he's like one
of those David Koresh kind of characters
we're charming lose a lot of women Betty
calls him a huckster mm which is some
one word someone who goes door-to-door
selling things Betty thinks of him as
like this guy who kind of considers
himself like a disciple in his own God
and as one does because one does being
the leader of a cult and I think you
know that Betty thinks that he's
brainwashed all of these people these
poor people that she has to figure out
what he's done to her mom because her
mom is so different than what she used
to be and I think Betty misses the old
Alice in a way sad absence makes the
heart grow stronger she would rather
have the uptight I think she would
rather than oh that's a mimic brain why
yeah it was beneficial for the feast
that he made and baking of the cookies
yeah all right what do you River babes
think do you think the Edgar ever never
is the man in black do you think that
the farm is tied to gng hits the
comments right now and tell me your
theories and our last comment comes from
Elijah Martinez who wrote this is not
for the episode but for the promo for
the next episode hisses - Archie with
another girl that really fired me up and
if for some reason you have not already
watched the promo for episode 307
then you're in luck because I just so
happened to have it right here roll it
there's something about this place
itches that makes me feel at home
everybody's running from something
seriously what one hand of blackjack
winner takes all
this isn't Riverdale hi you'd been a
very bad girl Betty
restrain her okay here are my initial
thoughts first get the heck off Archie
you little farm floozy secondly Veronica
looks to die for with a red lip and
third we need to get Betty out of the
sisters of quiet gargoyles immediately
I'm praying for you girl oh and then
there's Ethel hi Ethel
so do you river babes remember last year
in episode 207 chapter 20 tales from the
dark side when the episode was broken up
into three little stories well the
Riverdale writers have done it again
except this time the three tales will be
focusing on Veronica's speakeasy woes
Betty's trying time in the sisters of
quiet mercy and Archie and Jughead
small-town adventures are you excited
good because I'm about to thrill you
even more with my three tantalizing
clues about episode 307 here we go
number one
beware of foes disguised as friends
number two hell hath no fury like a
fictional princess scorned and number
three of our three tales one will end
semi happily one will break your heart
and one will push up on to its breaking
point and there you have it thank you so
much for watching this preview show for
episode 307 and be sure to check back to
Sweetwater secrets with me after you've
watched chapter 42 the man in black for
an exclusive interview with KJ APPA
talking about the new big twist until
then please give this video a like hit
subscribe so you never miss any of my
sweet letter secrets goodies and then
creep your way into the comments below
to tell me what you think is gonna
happen in 307 who do you think the man
in black really is what are your
thoughts about Edgar ever and ever
could he be connected to G&G too and can
you crack my three clues shout it all
out for me in the comments and I'll see
you after the episode river babes
toodles
[Music]